Or
where should we start? A record between
technological communication technologies. I ask with
broadband policies, high speed, the foundational band
and next-generation technologies. The need is really
very easy. All that matters is getting to be able to
transmit and receive instantly,
songs or video, making cheaper phone calls,
and calls today to the model
and friends wherever they are.  Working from home was the same
as in the case of Hanna, watching
TV programs with the doctor or followed by,
watching video on demand, having fun with
student friends via the Internet, obtaining
instant storage of data via the Internet, which is
sharing with family, friends, etc.
Among all the technologies and solutions, it
is the fastest and most effective way.  To
access the Internet
and other things, then the subject of the Internet is a lot of
a thousand, especially with the increased pressure on the network
available by users in the same
area. The
Internet via satellite is also much
better than what hinders
telephone conversations and other interactive activities. The
following are useful
at the same time.  It may take an hour to download a minute and
twenty minutes, and this is if you are lucky and
there is no member of your family using the Internet
at the same time. This
is the direct speed method to your home,
office or building. How is this possible, simply because the
optical sounds are very glassy, ​​what rings the
capillaries through which the light travels? Have you heard?
About the speed of light, this is exactly what, yes, it
may change.
You can get your favorite movie in a few minutes,
even if the children are on a call, and
this is not all, because its
future does not help unlimited.
Several million European homes have already
enjoyed the features in a day and you have
high-speed Internet.